さあ皆さん一粒で佐治社長ですだけど今日はですね
マイ週間前ほどに皆さんから僕の新しい名前を
コメントで頂いたんでまあ本当に
まずはたくさんのコメありがとうございますすべて見たわけですよコメントを
まあそん中から選び抜いたコメントで
今日は僕の名前を
決めようっていうことです
dendo
細工から神よ3
これはねー
確認を笑ってしまった僕亀田興毅じゃないですか
ああ
角さんありがとうございまーす
本名はそうですね
考えておきますずありがとうございます
もう何で僕
もう普通に笑いましたね簡単って思う
妙に簡単にてるねありがとうございます
悪くない
ncl 悪くないけど
たぶん違う
パトリシア
だめです
なんかもやしっても何か僕の体型とばですよね
もやしっぽいですけど
もやしって言う名前は嫌です
完全にも僕はもやしとしか見てないんですねありがとうございます
おや仕掛かりぞ
おかしいでしょ独歩流どっぽりー
は悪くないな悪くないけどしない
おかしいでしょ
yard たまに投げてついてるけどめげ cebo
今日1女グセボンバーですなっていっ
言わないよ
いやーこれは正
これは下ねどあー
同期少なくて
やはりゴーゴーっても馬鹿にしてんだろ2
雰囲気がウサギっぽくてー手足が長くてタコみたいから歌いもん
うさぎっぽいですか
手足が長い買った方ですよ
うさぎ2本
2位です2
bdr 3hl の本当の名前でおよしの日に
おかしいず自然ですよ
やバルいけないですこれを
始めようぜすと何か王子ってなんかかっこいいけど
会社で締められそうな気がする区
道
ダークサクリファイスてこう暗黒の池に行ってみですよ
今日は暗黒の生贄です
これはもう名前じゃなくても番組例だな感じ未明
すっ
あまいめろ的な感じですか
始めろ
可愛らしいですね
ずメロディー
これもキックマイメロディーなぁ
僕そんな前メロディーに見えますかああ
例外はずも
完全に僕前迷路ですねもう
はメロディでいいかなーう
いやおかしいでしょよパレスこの部屋のことだよ僕で4番じゃない
それ違う
wh
ん
うん